c'est une catastrophe écologique qui
créé des remous jusqu'au sommet de
l'état et qui a même provoqué la colère
de vladimir poutine quand le gouverneur
dans la région de krasnoïarsk avoué
n'avoir réalisé l'ampleur des dégâts que
deux jours après les faits via les
réseaux sociaux
le président russe très mécontents
rapidement recadré le patron de ntech
l'entreprise incriminée
pourquoi les agences gouvernementales
dont elle été mise au courant que deux
jours plus tard allons nous découvrir
les situations d'urgence sur les réseaux
sociaux
est-ce que tout va bien dans votre tête
dans la foulée vladimir poutine a
décrété l'état d'urgence afin de
mobiliser plus facilement les ressources
requises
car les dégâts pourraient être
importants ce sont près de 20 mille
tonnes de diesel qui se sont déversés
dans la rivière locale et les opérations
de nettoyage s'avère compliqué car la
rivière en question n'est pas navigables
car trop peu profondes et en plus
éloignés des routes d'après le
gouverneur de cette région qui s'est
rendu sur place en compagnie du ministre
des situations d'urgence
ce dernier a cependant déclaré par la
suite qu'une solution a été trouvée pour
récupérer le carburant
en attendant des barrages ont été
installés sur la rivière pour éviter que
cette nappe rouge ne descendent plus en
aval ntech l'entreprise fautive filiale
du géant industriel russe nornickel
prétend de son côté avoir signalé
l'incident aux autorités
rapidement après l'avoir constaté mais
quoi qu'il en soit les faits sont là il
ya clairement eu des manquements dans la
chaîne de commande ce qui a eu pour
conséquence de perdre un temps précieux
alors qu'il fallait circonscrire la
catastrophe au plus vite